- [Narrator] There's lots of
amazing food in the Philippines,
but there's one amazing culinary tradition
that's big enough to feed an army.
- Hi, I'm Japh, and I
own Boodle Fight Manila.
- [Narrator] Boodle, Boodle what?
What's a Boodle Fight?
(playful music)
- [Japh] A Boodle Fight is a
feast set up on banana leaves.
Just a food pile in the middle
with everyone standing
shoulder to shoulder
and the best part is everyone
eats with their bare hands.
- [Narrator] It originated
with the Philippine Military.
Soldiers took the practice
home and it went mainstream,
so mainstream that chefs like
Japh now have full-time jobs
bringing Boodle Fights to the masses.
The Boodle Fight is a
quintessential example
of how Filipinos value sharing.
- Especially when it comes to food.
A lot of food is needed for Boodle Fight
to be enjoyed the way it's meant to be.
We love Balintawak Market.
This is where Boodle Fight comes together.
We'll be needing the essentials.
Pork, chicken, seafood,
veggies, dessert, the sides
and of course, the fruits
and do not forget the start of the show,
the banana leaves.
- [Narrator] I am full already.
- We start with the
messy part, the grilling.
First the pork,
chicken, the seafood and
then you slice the fruits,
steam the veggies together with the shrimp
and the crab and then slice all the sides
and prepare the table.
After setting up the banana leaves
it is important to look
for the center of the table
and start from there.
You can place the dessert and fruits.
Then on both sides start with the rice,
pork, chicken and seafood.
To make it extra delicious
add the sides literally
on the side of the table.
- [Narrator] The Philippines
has a lot of choices
when it comes to food,
but none compare to the community
that develops when sharing
a pile of food barehanded
with the people you love.
(lively music)